when you have that passion you will get
back up when you get knocked down all
sorts of people say all sorts of things
they are our perspective is to keep our
heads down I feel like the luckiest
person in the world every day because of
what I get to do you know I think you
have to believe in yourself I think that
the minute that you have a back-up plan
you've admitted that you're not going to
succeed my journey was one of jumping in
feet first and there's nothing like
rolling your sleeves up and failing a
bunch of times to figure out how to do
it right I've always seen money as a
tool right for being able to make a
difference big waves come and they go
but you're there for a reason in this
evening were lives piscine when you're
talking about someone that you love
you'd do anything she's an American
businesswoman and entrepreneur she's a
CEO of a bloodfest company founded in
2003 as of January 2016 Forbes estimated
her net worth to be three point six
billion dollars
she's Elizabeth Holmes and here her top
ten rules for success I would focus
first on why you're doing what you're
doing and really really understand
what's if you're building a company
what's the reason that you're building
this company and what is the role that
you want to have and and why are you
there because once you understand it you
understand your reason for it you'll
build the company differently yeah I
would say to make sure that what you're
doing is something that you love and
that you are so deeply and incredibly
passionate about that if you got fired
you would still want to do it and if you
weren't CEO you would still want to do
it because when you have that passion
you will get back up when you get
knocked down and you will get knocked
down over and over and over and over
again and you win by getting back up and
our journey has been nothing but that in
the context of falling in love with this
mission and feeling like the luckiest
people on the planet to be able to do it
every single day and and fighting for it
because we love it so much and
and I've always been a great believer in
the concept of the 10,000 hour rule when
you go so deep in something you can
become an expert in it and when you love
it that much you don't let it go and and
I think I think that's what winning is
about having people all sorts of people
say all sorts of things yeah I have our
our perspective is to keep our heads
down and we have a very clear mission
yeah we know why we're doing this we see
every day what this means to people in
the context of the ability to afford
care or not go through and what I equate
to torture in the context of traditional
phlebotomy and and that's what we focus
on and that's all that we focus on
because if we can keep doing that person
by person we will realize this mission
what keeps Elizabeth up at night if you
sleep and how do you go about tackling
that I don't sleep very much how many
hours do you get a night on average I
sleep about four hours yeah yeah um you
know I I feel like the luckiest person
in the world every day because of what I
get to do and right now building this
company is about building people and
really investing in building the people
from within our company so um I spend as
much of my time as humanly possible
focusing on getting and building the
right people because that's how we
realize this mission and how we realize
this dream so hey I don't think I could
be possibly kept up more than I already
am on that one I mean the first time
that that I went through the process of
raising money I assumed that I was going
to have to talk to at least 200 people
before I found one who was going to
believe in me so I didn't really care if
people returning me down because I knew
I would find someone who did
I'm how do you how do you make people
believe in you I'm you know I think you
have to believe in yourself and I think
you have to have the conviction in
yourself to be able to make something
happened because ultimately it's up to
you and um when you have that level of
conviction you'll find the people or the
resources or the tools that you need to
make it happen it it may take a lot
longer than you think but it's about
keeping that conviction in yourself so
did you have a back-up plan I mean you
know what if this didn't work out you
know
what was what was your alternative did
you did you have one no and I think that
I think the minute that you have a
back-up plan you've admitted that you're
not going to succeed and so we are not
big on backup plans my journey was one
of jumping in feet first and so and I
think if you know why you're doing
something and what it is that you're
trying to get then it's a question of
being very very open to failure and I'm
and just you know trying again and again
and again until you get it right
and so we codenamed our product what
started as that patch the Edison because
our premise was we will fail over a
thousand times until we get this thing
to work but we will get it on mm and
first time and I'm and I think I think
that mindset has really guided so much
of what we've done because there's a
determination to make it work no matter
what but you're not you're not worried
about whether many of those attempts
fail you're embracing it almost how have
you managed you know those are different
skill sets founding and running a
company how have you developed each of
those skill sets and how have you
managed to you know lead this company
from a small organization to a big you
know big
startup still that startup today yeah
hopefully will always be a start-up yeah
and we we've had the privilege of and I
have had the privilege of surrounding
ourselves with and myself I have
incredibly smart people and I'm that
combined with
jumping in and doing it and I'm and
teaching myself I'm is the way that that
I've approached everything that I've
done and done and there's nothing like
rolling your sleeves up and failing a
bunch of times to figure out how to do
it right I've always seen money as a
tool right for being able to make a
difference and for us we reinvest
everything that we make back into our
company and we always will because it's
about being able to create better and
better products to realize this vision
and so I'm so I never would have built
the company this way if it was about
making money
it's it's about creating value and and
money becomes a byproduct of being
successful in creating that value and
then and then it's a tool to reinvest in
being able to continue doing that right
and that's that's how we think about it
I've been knocked down a lot and I
became really clear that this was what I
wanted to do and that I would start this
company over ten thousand times if I had
to and I'm you know there's there's been
times where we've invested in people who
you build something like this and I'm
and I mean to me the people in our
company has always been like my family
and you make mistakes and you hire the
wrong people and sometimes that can be
incredibly painful because the damage
that they can do to the company yeah is
really significant I'm now you know
we're under a real attack from the lab
industry who you know is is seeding all
sorts of bad stuff about us into the
press or false statements about us and
we've had to i'm we've had to keep our
heads down and focus on what we're doing
and the belief that i'm person by person
we will demonstrate the integrity of
what we do yeah but but I think that
clarity of purpose in terms of why we do
it and makes you capable of weathering
it's kind of like an ocean you know
has come and they go but you're there
for a reason I have I've always believed
that you were we're here on this earth
to try to make a difference in the world
and so and so when I I found what I felt
like I was born to do which was to try
to help contribute to solving a problem
that that I believe you know at a human
level there's not a lot that matters max
as Modell's save more lives yeah and the
saving more lives piecing when you're
talking about someone that you love
you'd do anything right and and to be
able to to solve that problem to me that
was the greatest contribution I could
make with my life thank you guys so much
for watching I made this video because
one of you guys asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know which of Elizabeth Holmes is top
ten rules is hip to the harness of the
biggest impact leave it in the comments
and we'll join the discussion and one
last thing my goal with the channel is
to get it to 1 million subscribers as
the next goal so anything you can do the
think of to share the video tell friends
about it tweet it out of the playlist
spread the message a little bit I really
really really appreciate it thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon